[Music]
[Applause]
we'll talk to Chris Sims pro football
talk you'll join us coming on his
quarterback rankings going into the
draft
Frank Reich the Carolina Panthers head
coach at a press conference and
he was
he was addressing a lot of things it
felt like and he didn't need to but it
had to do with the height of Bryce young
in Alabama and would he consider him
with the number one pick
everything matters all those
conversations matter especially when
it's you know Scott fitter you know it's
the GM and he's talking about a guy like
Russell Wilson who by the way I had a
very high grade on don't you don't have
to read anything into that but I don't
mind telling you that I had a high grade
on Russell Wilson okay but don't read
anything into it I'm just saying that
because all these people putting this
label on me that only work with big
quarterbacks don't read anything into
that when you got the number one pick
the thing is is right you know we don't
have to play games right I mean it's not
like we're trying to fool anybody what
we're trying to do is take all the time
we can on the evaluation there's a lot
of conviction as Scott said on some of
these top quarterbacks and you're right
the old adage don't make a decision
before you have to we're going to take
every second every day or every hour
every day to make this decision and we
still got plenty of time left okay you
don't have to explain anything Frank you
have the number one pick
you you didn't clear up anything other
other than hey I had a great grade on
Russell Wilson don't read anything into
that okay because Russ is six feet tall
and Bryce young is five ten but we're
not going to read anything into that
Chris Sims pro football talk live
co-host NBC football night in America
analyst what's Frank Reich saying or not
saying
uh I think he's you know he's still
toting the line of like I'm not we're
not sure what we're gonna do here yet
right that's the that's the great thing
I think what Carolina did here Dan I
mean they were kind of in no man's land
as far as the number nine pick of the
draft right you're in danger of weight
we might not get one of the top guys so
they make a move here nobody is fully
confident in their draft board as it
stands right now in the middle of March
team just ended free agency so what they
did in the premium they paid to get to
number one is now to go wait we got the
pick of the litter and we can have
evaluated this and so he's just trying
to make sure guys like you and me can't
glean anything to where they're leaning
or anything like that right now uh and
I'm sure they don't 100 know exactly
what they're gonna do as of right now
okay
your Carolina's GM yeah you're taking
who number one overall uh I'm taking CJ
Stroud and it's not I mean I'm I'm a big
CJ Stroud fan I I think he's kind of in
a Class by Himself okay walk me through
the evaluation because you said this
isn't close CJ Stroud is the best
quarterback going into the draft right
CJ Stroud I mean one Hey listen the size
thing and then you know compared to my
number two quarterback and Bryce young
yeah that's a real issue it's concerning
one for Bryce young two sizes of
strength it's a skill right we talk
about this a lot right Dan the ability
for the bigger quarterbacks to throw
with people hanging around them I can't
step up and into step into this throw
but I still am big enough and strong
enough to throw a 20-yard out route so I
I always lean towards that but then when
you break down CJ Stroud like I I guess
I was a little Blown Away by the fact of
one his decision making is burn
borderline flawless I think it's about
as good as I've seen other than maybe
Joe burrow he's the only guy I would
maybe give the edge to as far as that
department and then throwing the
football mechanics are flawless and it's
not like it's Dink and dunk and screams
and all that type of stuff Dan it's 1 15
and 20 and 25 yard throw after another
you know and and of course I think the
movement is underrated a little bit
there's still some untapped potential in
this kid so yeah I'm uh he's clearly
number one for me and I would be shocked
if more people don't see it that way as
uh the NFL evaluators continue to go
through the process well trying to
evaluate Ohio State quarterbacks and
Alabama quarterbacks because yeah other
receivers Ohio state has become wide
receiver you yeah and how does that
factor in when you're looking at CJ
Stroud going uh he's got some of the
best wide receivers in college for sure
sure no I I mean I I definitely look at
that you know that was one of the things
that even like you know with Justin
Fields back to that conversation you
weren't sure about but you know also
within that the offense is a little
different than what they ran with Justin
Fields you get to see so many throws and
CJ Stroud play like a professional
quarterback with decision making the
concepts down the field how he moves in
the pocket that you know hey yeah Dan
there's some guys that are wide open but
you know what happens every time they're
wide open it's on the money and they
keep running it's a touchdown so he
takes advantage of that to its utmost
but as you know too there's plenty of
there's plenty of plays where coverage
is tight oh my gosh whoa yeah this is
the only guy that's open this is an NFL
window he's only open by four or five
inches boom strike I mean it's one
really great throw after another and
he's pretty aggressive in his decision
making but not crazy aggressive uh so
yeah you take all those things into an
account but you get to see plenty of you
know other stuff that's not easy from CJ
Stroud there okay you're seeing it yeah
our other analysts our other you know
teams going to see this
I I think so I I like this why haven't
they seen it though Chris I said all you
got to do is put in the Georgia game
right I think well again I think you
know Talking Heads the media the hype
around Bryce young it is Alabama he won
a Heisman all that is gonna lend itself
we've been everybody's been been told
that Bryce young was the number one pick
for a long long time you know and as I
said too you know I think NFL evaluators
are just really getting into this where
I do think as time goes on I have a hard
time thinking that yeah they're gonna
start going oh no CJ Stroud is clearly
number one you know and this isn't to me
this isn't like a Zack Wilson Trevor
Lawrence ooh it's so close um I'm
nitpicky or I'm trying to be you know
different because I like a strong armed
quarterback or anything like that no
this dude checks all the boxes and then
like you said some of the untapped
potential that you see in the Georgia
game where you go oh the backyard
element the ability to run it's there
more than he's given it credit for but
that should have been the you know the
point that dry at home that he can do it
just about against anybody all right you
brought up Zach Wilson
yeah you liked him more than Trevor
Lawrence I did right
do you still do you still like him more
than Trevor Lawrence well of course not
I mean how you know how you know how do
you do that Trevor Lawrence has entered
the top five quarterbacks in football
conversation now again I'm not saying
this is over that's the other thing too
I mean after year one I was looking like
hey Zach Wilson was the better
quarterback Chris Sims was right here
too yeah negative Ghost Rider certainly
and again Dan I think you know me well
enough I'm if I'm wrong I'm wrong I'm
not gonna sit here and try to re-justify
myself 74 different times here
so so yeah Trevor Lawrence right now is
on a Skyrocket to to super stardom right
see what I I get nervous about the one
and done quarterbacks Zach Wilson was a
one and done quarterback where they do
one thing they do it for one year
whereas I got to see a body of work the
sample size was larger with Trevor
Lawrence and some of these other
quarterbacks sure it's just and you have
more available that you can critique and
analyze Zach Wilson had one I think
really tough game and that was Coastal
Carolina he didn't look good yeah no I I
listen you're right that's experience
you know more to evaluate those are all
positive things you know it's one of the
reasons like you know the Hendon hooker
I have him right there at number three
quarterback in the draft behind Bryce
young and you know when I look at him I
go okay wait you know great thrower
great decision maker right he's a
another guy that's an underrated athlete
he can play NFL style quarterback he
could throw over people see over people
make those type of throws but people are
using his age against him and I want to
go wait we're not marrying these guys
are we worried about what he's going to
look like when he's 51 and we roll over
in bed we're talking about the next four
or five years and then we'll go from
there I mean if it's a 15-year problem
that's a great thing to have but I would
rather and be a hair more mature and
played a little bit rather than the
other way around so I hope he gives you
negative yeah I hope he gets a chance
because that that was a great story this
past year we're talking to Chris Sims
pro football talk live co-host give me
the quarterback that you're down on
well I'm I'm probably more down than the
rest of the public on will Levis right
will Levis I have him tied at number
five with uh Dorian Thompson Robinson
where I don't understand why he's not in
the conversation here a little bit more
but Levis hey I see all the potential
you know like like Richardson you know
there's there's a really high ceiling
but I think there's a pretty low floor
there too and you know what I think is I
look at it one I don't love is throwing
uh motion his mechanics There's real
like flaws that are tangible there that
lead to inconsistencies you know you
take his 10 or 15 best throws Dan and
you go oh my gosh that's as good as
anybody on the planet but you know then
you could see 10 or 15 throws in that
same game and go damn he's better than
that how does he miss that or why does
you know why did the ball leave his hand
like that so decision making wasn't the
best consistency and throwing mechanics
I thought he was the worst in the pocket
out of all the quarterback facts that
are in that top conversation you know
and then you know his ability to to run
is really probably least out of all the
quarterbacks there so yeah I'm a little
more down on them I guess than the rest
of the public I like DTR
I I don't get the DTR thing I don't get
it Dan I turned it on and I went wait
does this guy did he like get did he get
arrested did what did his he's selling
drugs on the corner at one point I don't
understand if he played in Alabama right
and you put Bryce young at UCLA then we
would be talking about Dorian Thompson
right you see you're starting to think
like me here that that's you that's
that's the that's exactly so I'm sitting
there going wait he's four inches taller
than Bryce young he's faster than Bryce
young he has a stronger arm than Bryce
young but we're talking about him as a
sixth round pick that it just it makes
no sense I don't get it he played in a
good system you get to see decisions he
plays the quarterback position the right
way yeah he's a little frail he plays
smaller than the 6-2 frame he can have a
little bit of a wind-up and emotion but
damn those are minor things I I
somebody's gonna get a steal with DTR
I'm really interested to see where he
ends up falling in the strap when it's
all said and done Dan what did you think
of Jordan love
yeah I I I liked Jordan Love's potential
right I at first was kind of like oh I
think I might like Jordan love a little
bit better than Tua but as I started to
dive into it a little bit I just started
to go man you know a little too raw has
to fix some things decision making wise
and even his throwing was a little all
over the place but you had Jordan love
ranked above Tua and I did you had
burrow Herbert Jordan loved Tua Jacob I
did and I switched uh I think you know I
rarely switch you know that but like
about two weeks before the draft
I switched to uh and Jordan love and I
just but you know what I'm a little too
in love with the Jordan love potential
and the reality of the situation is
there's some things he needs to fix so
that's where I kind of readjusted that
but hey we saw a little last year he's
an athlete he's got some size in his arm
you know he's fixed a few of those
mechanics and he's he's got a chance
here to be something so I'm excited for
his opportunity this year explain to me
why there's no market for Lamar Jackson
and why it felt like every team sent out
an email blast at the same time to say
we're not interested in Lamar Jackson
and I'm not supposed to read into
collusion that they don't want to if you
give him the same contract as to Sean
Watson you've opened the door for the
Bengals and the Chargers and the Eagles
that they may have to eat that as well
yeah it's it's a deep subject you know
one I you know the the the teams
releasing those type of statements first
off they were asked by people's members
of the media because oh wait he's
franchise let me call team that doesn't
have quarterback hey do you want Lamar
Jackson so they were compelled to kind
of make but it came out all at once I
know it looks weird I I get it but but
that's what everybody did if you got to
look at it some certain beat writers
connected to the team as soon as they
saw the non-exclusive franchise tag they
called their team and got a quote from
it you know I don't think this is this
is different than Kaepernick or some of
the other ones Lamar's loved in the NFL
this isn't I don't think this is like
one where the owners called each other
up but like hey we don't want Lamar no
they know though Chris they've already
had this discussion with DeSean Watson I
exactly they didn't even have to have
the discussion that's what I'm saying
once you sign him let's say you're the
Colts right
I would think about it seriously yeah I
would you know I the culture one team
that I look at and if you know hey
you're looking to get a pocket passing
quarterback I don't know you might not
be comfortable with one that's left with
you at number four right Lamar Jackson
can do it all I'm sick of everybody kind
of saying oh it needs to be in a certain
offense wait we know we can run we got
that he can sit in the pocket and throw
the ball with the best of them so yes I
would think that but I think it's all
the other stuff too that doesn't help
him out being injured the last two years
at the end of the year you know
um tons of mispractices over the years
because of illnesses or whatever else
the style of play which is physical and
then I think also the headache and the
perception that's out there that Lamar
can't get a deal done and if he's happy
and we get him and we sign him and then
he's not happy with the deal two or
three years down the road oh crap we're
right back into this same boat of we
can't get them done we can't get the
details hashed out he's not happy so I
think there's things like that that are
more hurting Lamar rather than the
player or the person and that's where it
stinks he doesn't have an agent to kind
of get his message out there he needs
Odell Beckham Jr as his agent because
nobody gets more talk Whispers rumors
speculation than obj uh let me ask you
who has a bigger impact Baker Mayfield
to the bucks or Garoppolo to the Raiders
oh
they're both good there uh you know I
I'll say Garoppolo to the Raiders
um you know the Raiders I I guess you
know what I look at there is I he knows
that system well do I put Derek Carr in
there as well if I put card of the
Saints Garoppolo the Raiders and maybe
it's not fair to Baker going to the
Bucks because they're they may not be as
good that's that's the that's where I
was leaning because it's the bait you
know the Bucks are I think in a little
bit of a rebuild phase here and that's
why I was gonna favor the Garoppolo
situation the familiarity with McDaniels
you do have you know a pretty good Trio
and receivers as far as uh Devonte Adams
Renfro Jacoby Myers he got one of the
best running backs in football so that's
the possible but Derek Carr That's one
like for real Dan you're right about
that after
team that though top five-ish tennis
that oh line is still good and now you
couple Michael Thomas coming back with
Crystal Lobby and Rasheed Shaheed and
Kamara still got a little tread on the
tires like they could be a player when
this is all said and done I like that
move by Derek Carr and the Saints all
right I'll leave you with this right now
Cam Newton could be a starting
quarterback a respectable backup
quarterback a good TV analyst
hmm
I'd probably go with good TV analysts
okay I don't think
he's not a starting quarterback and I
don't think Cam Newton is made to be a
backup not to say he can't but I've
always felt and I've always said this
that he's a guy that needs reps and
throw in and Rhythm he's not your ideal
let's just Puck him off the bench in
week 10 and he'll get hit the ground
running that's not what he is plus as a
backup as you know he's a polarizing
figure he's a natural leader guys
gravitate towards him the locker room
he's built like a Greek god it can be a
little bit threatening to a starter when
Cam Newton's walking around as a backup
TV million dollar smile great
personality Charisma hope he doesn't
steal my job
good to talk to you thanks as always
amen all right I'll always say hi to the
guys Chris Sims got his uh
quarterbacks here that he ranks and he
doesn't shy away from criticism I mean
that's what I love he he makes his
analysis he has his grades and he sticks
by it